ante la prohibición de vuelos desde y
hacia reino unido- ordenada por algunas
naciones tras la confirmación de que la
nueva variante del virus detectada en
dicho territorio estaba fuera de control
la comisión europea se pronunció
sugiriendo que estas medidas preventivas
sean suprimidas nuestra recomendación
para garantizar un enfoque coordinado de
la unión europea a las restricciones de
viajes de reino unido
se desaconsejan los viajes no esenciales
pero se debe facilitar el tránsito deben
cesar las prohibiciones de vuelos y
trenes es necesario evitar
interrupciones en la cadena de
suministros y aunque se han observado
nuevas cepas de kobe 19 casi desde que
apareció en china hace un año esta nueva
variante detectada por primera vez en
septiembre es mucho más contagiosa lo
que significa que ahora se está
convirtiendo rápidamente en la cepa
dominante inglaterra causando alrededor
del 60 por ciento de las nuevas
infecciones en londres ya que el reino
unido- reportó más de 30 mil casos
nuevos por segundo día consecutivo
los virus mutan con el tiempo es natural
y esperado el reino unido ha informado
que esta nueva variante se transmite más
fácilmente pero hasta ahora no hay
evidencia de que sea más probable que
cause enfermedades graves o mortalidad
es por mortality pero incluso si la
última cepa resulta ser más peligrosa el
director de variante que junto a facer
desarrollaron la primera vacuna aprobada
en europa dice que deberían poder
hacerle frente a esta nueva amenaza en
poco tiempo no sabemos por el momento si
nuestra vacuna también puede brindar
protección contra esta nueva variante
pero científicamente es muy probable que
la respuesta inmune de esta vacuna
también puede hacer frente a las nuevas
variantes podemos comenzar a diseñar una
vacuna que imite esta nueva mutación y
podríamos proporcionar una nueva vacuna
técnicamente en seis semanas
sin embargo la atención se ha extendido
internacionalmente ya se han detectado
casos en varias naciones europeas como
países bajos bélgica e italia